[Music]
ever seen this map this is how the earth
look 200 million years ago before
Pangaea the only super continent on the
planet came apart what if one day the
continents joined together into one
giant landmass again and you could
travel from North America to Africa on
foot what country would become your new
neighbor with this cause natural
disasters all over the planet how long
would this new Pangaea last for this is
what if and here's what would happen if
the continents merge together did you
know the land below you is actually
moving right now this is because all
seven continents sit on the tectonic
plates that Earth's crust is broken into
these plates are floating on molten rock
at the same speed your fingernails grow
it may sound slow but it does add up
over hundreds of millions of years in
the four-and-a-half billion year history
of Earth our comments have changed their
appearance many times sometimes fusing
together and crunching collisions and
sometimes breaking apart right now
they're slowly moving toward another
collision what if one day they suddenly
sped up and smashed into a
supercontinent again would you wake up
to find yourself at the Mexican border
the world would look very different than
what you're used to if the plates
collided in the direction they're moving
now the flight from Australia to Asia
would never be cheaper since Australia
would collide with Japan Korea and China
the two continents would no longer be
separated by the Atlantic Ocean
and if you're really into walking you'd
also be able to travel from sunny
Australia to the world's coldest
continent Antarctica on foot North
America would bump into western Africa
citizens of New York might wake up to
find Namibian Lions roaming through
Central Park the northern part of Africa
would crash into Europe this would
create a new Himalayan scale mountain
range on the border of the tectonic
plates think camels would enjoy a chilly
day on a snow hill some of these changes
may sound fun but there would be some
really bad news to the eastern side of
the Americas along with Western Europe
and Africa would turn into an earthquake
danger zone on top of that these areas
would be devastated by the eruptions of
newly formed volcanoes green slopes of
the Appalachians would become giant
snow-covered mountains spewing ash and
lava this new Pangaea would be mostly
arid and hot as rain clouds would lose
most of their moisture before getting
too far inland the supercontinent would
be centered at the equator wildlife
would become less diverse as not all
species can bear hot temperatures but
just like the most recent continental
mashup this reunion wouldn't last
forever
well not longer than 50 million years
volcanic eruptions would be spewing out
large amounts of lava and gas add
devastating earthquakes to the equation
and you'd see these dangerous regions
start to pull themselves apart
stirred by hot currents below the
supercontinent would eventually break
apart into smaller continents going
their separate ways
if bordering Australia looks like a cool
thing to you bad luck you won't see this
happening anytime soon but you can
always imagine how the world would look
if the giant continental pieces of the
puzzle came together give the planet 300
million years and there'll be another
supercontinent geologists already gave
it a name Pangaea Ultima what would you
name it
you